hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to kill the bad guy
now if you can't figure out what you're
doing this game that you really
shouldn't be watching my videos just a
little bit too complicated for someone
over your intelligence probably the
first time anyone's called my videos
intelligent so I probably shouldn't be
insulting you guys I make funny noises
and I do stupid stuff to make people
laugh on the internet not that you guys
are done I'm just saying that I'm very
very very dumb probably anyways big
swinging ball meet bad guy boom and he
goes flying off into blood anyway back
to the game I haven't been talking about
the game yet you try to kill the bad guy
and he dies in a spectacular way now we
have lit we have reached the level of my
expertise because that's the only level
that it played before I started
recording so now I'm really gonna look
like an idiot because I have no idea
what I'm doing but I am gonna save right
now this game I love the style of it I
absolutely have the style of it I'm a
very minimalistic guy when it comes to
the styling in both games in the end
like my house and whatnot like things
that I have I love minimalism and this
one has just this cool style and the
music is not bad either
but anyway what am I trying to do here
hold and click beside the slide with J
up with the havoc if ya look a little
shook up my own spit you'll have to wait
until sabotage is finished
keep pressing charges oh okay so I got a
click a real hard right I had to click
the ball and now I gotta click someone
well what am i doing what am i doing how
am i doing that what is it doing
is it an advanced or what what am i
doing what happened
times oh now it's ready oh now it's oh
now it's ready I get nothing
hey I did not know that I got another
day for this shindig kill them come on
walk into my path of death
that's plenty of play to do I also have
no words oh no no no no no no no
all I have to hold it down that's right
you're lucky you're lucky this day you
get a walk away but the next day you
might get another pick swinging Paul in
the back of the head that you won't see
coming that time okay so I gonna hold it
oh well okay if I didn't know that it
was gonna be done by the time I was done
clicking on it
I wasn't it clicked it out early so that
I would look like an idiot for the whole
internet even though that's kind of my
job at this point in my life but this is
besides the point because that douche
over there is gonna walk away and have
another nice day for me or the bad guy
I'm over here looking like an [ __ ]
so I by yourself in there but I mean I
want to go back to my big swing ball
okay so I gotta hold it down not when it
gets cool oh there's a speedy uh P
button well this is just delightful I'm
very happy with this situation I didn't
know that I would have to be so
unbelievably why do I have to click it
first I already know that I want to kill
him maybe oh come on what is this below
yeah you run up know what he saw it
coming what I did back [ __ ] ask
mother humper he's a pumpernickel bread
son of a biscuit eater mother humper bag
of monkey ass piece of cockney crapola
I'm adding insult psycho it's all the
insult a guy bag over his head got a
target on the front of his face was
waiting for a sniper to come pick him
off in those nuts that's putting blade
of death not nuts oh no you had your
feet chopped off holy crap that's
awesome I win I like how the crosses
just right over his head and paled him
to death okay now that I got a good feel
for this game I'm gonna blow up that car
so he doesn't know ah saboteur
I don't think I meant to set off that
alarm you might have known something
about that okay so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna oh my goodness what you didn't
tell me about that supposed to know you
didn't give me any instructions no
you're the douche in this scenario how
my own source of sabotage though is
probably zero a way to oh there's
another car there's another car car
alarms go off all the time in the city
everyone ignores them you need to just
keep walking and ignoring them even
though your friend was taken out by a
big swinging ball and the other guy was
taken out by a rather precarious
spinning fan not worry your pretty
little head
and keep on walking into death how about
that music pretty cool reminds me of us
what was that one game tomorrow's not
enough now it was like a the the female
James Bond type it was really really
interesting I loved it oh god what was
the name of that game well oh my god
Oh didn't explode I was totally
expecting it to explode down the road
there Oh God
that is very good win I win I'm the best
your ever was okay now what do I do
do I see any war okay he's going over
there so I got a I got a sabotage a few
cars here oh god oh don't pay no mind oh
goodness
you kidding me I know exactly what I
need to do you're gonna die you son of a
[ __ ] click OH
just in time to the exact right time I
really appreciate your candor than that
all my goodness I love it I love it some
object can be associated to be used
differently and some odds they think
that without I can't read these words
these words are in a different language
that I don't understand
I see rope I see you I see I think I see
that I see rope I know what you want me
to do here
but just let me do it yeah and say
anything you're just gonna keep on
walking bloody so that I can get this
rope and pianer I'm gonna fight yeah
what are you doing okay who's just gonna
go running off into the abyss while I'm
gonna try me
oh wait a minute oh wait a minute
ooh aha okay I I didn't have enough time
but you were lucky you are a lucky man
okay so if I if I somehow figure out how
to tie this to appropriate no no no if I
somehow appropriate this stuff oh no oh
oh there oh oh I'm not ready to cut you
just yet you think that this guy walking
along in the middle of say it was like
that's a lovely piano right above my
head
oh no but he didn't have enough time to
say oh no cuz you squished like a
pancake into the ground by the pan of
those die oh boy he took my command a
little too literally and he died at a
rather spectacular fashion thank you for
you you win yes oh there's a police car
up there
well I don't think I need to worry about
that
so I don't have a big swinging ball but
they do have a rope and I do I've sort
of a spiky do not know how but I just
ran this through his skull how about
that what if I do that okay so what do
you woody what do you want for me what
do you want from a game you want for me
oh gosh just yeah whatever
the top doesn't even care the cap just
walked right by like why would he give
to asses about what's going on with that
we don't want to blow up the car what is
this
hotties mag I know I care about how what
distracted by the hotties mag who would
not want peace candy more piece of candy
are you gonna follow the hotties mags
all the way over there
what the hell is oh wait a minute no no
no no wait a minute what do i do what do
we do Oh what do we do ooh
oh no he's running away oh my
careful trap he was scared off by a rope
good for him I know what I need to do
though I know what I need to do so I
need to this rope needs to go here that
spike needs to go on the rope obviously
like that and then the hotties mags oh
look at the hotties mag over there oh
yeah oh come on I had that and you dick
well you know I see big jugs 28 you know
where they hold jugs of milk up to the
front of the magazine cover and then
take off their clothes like who wouldn't
want to see that you're gonna put your
hottie mag right there
ready sweep Lu is my spike you thought
that you would impale the women on that
magazine with your spike when in reality
euro now the cop doesn't care the top
doesn't give two asses about what
happened that stretching south with the
sound of his pants expanding and then
its skull being a bit oh this is getting
creative I really like this Frye juillet
so I gotta find someplace with no
coverage Oh dead dog that is really
disgusting and sad why why well I well
it was a dead dog yeah I would run away
cuz I'm scared of like a gun or
something but it was a dead dog Roy was
really gonna happen fine some bad guy
this is I mean what sort of mastermind
is this if he doesn't actually do
anything
I finally combine this with this deer
shorebird deer fight doesn't help me how
am I gonna get him over there get this
car to do something how's it gonna go
where I need him to go maybe you circle
around now every corners being watched I
bet he won't go over there does speed up
a bit now he's a cowardly coward of
cowards every day what a douche oh oh I
got it I got it
he's not gonna go down the road that
there's a dead dog because even it's
gross and it's gross so he's gonna see
that and he's gonna go the other way no
not that one no it's too obvious this
one the one that's more closer to the
ground the one that he could probably
more obviously see and now you don't
sudden
you're done there's no I had to save ya
you're dead you should have gone with it
your dog was please you wouldn't even
think that would kill anyone
well that guy's head it's just like a
tomato it just explodes on contact
come on TV store how am I gonna look
Annette really really real really really
Wow Wow what is that it dildo no that's
a piece of bread I am so sorry about
that that is that is bread that is bread
did not mean to put porn on there I
probably need to blur that up because
that's actually if you zoom in on that
it's very obscene very obscene very
obscene Lilly's gonna go oh yeah for the
good god for the baker oh this is with
you watch out a watermelon ooh ooh I
know how to scare him I know how okay I
know how to do this I know how to do
this I know exactly how to do this
because it's actually quite obvious if
you think about it it's quite obvious
indeed that piece of bread right in
front oh no is this some strange car
that ran out of nowhere
ah come on you dick just because someone
of the okay so I have got to distract
the other person with Piron and that's
why I'll be able to keep him from doing
what he wants to do
got some sabotage this oh no I had to
distract them - oh yeah did that count
Oh totally counted I would lose em oh
that was the TV he's over there okay was
about say Oh like what is going on here
how do I sabotage this one
what is that dynamite that's dynamite
oh my goodness gravy why oh that does
not look good what I know that walk into
that just walk into death walk into
death
okay now that did not work out but but
but I would rather that did I would have
liked that to work out oh well this
sucks ass I don't have my thing anymore
[Music]
what is this gonna run them away
Tamara's gonna see it
Oh No I'll call card screw you buddy
you're a bag of asses that I hit were
you ready
what oh my goodness I know exactly I'm
gonna beat this apparently and there was
a lighter over there I had no idea but I
I know exactly how to beat this now and
it's not what I expected I'm going to
run him around he's gonna run away from
this he's gonna circle back and he's
gonna run right into the fire I'm a
genius I am a genius
I am a genius everybody get ready for
this genius level grabber because this
is pretty good I even I will admit I'm a
baby bio genius because this is pretty
incredible I have do a bit I think this
might be the last to the next there were
only so many levels that were available
okay so there's that well that's cool
just a thing as spikes down in the
middle of the city no reason to worry
about that okay gonna close you out from
going this way good job - silver yah
that's a stop sign anything so then I'm
gonna put a bag what else do we have
here god there's so many things but I
don't know how to do it money you know
you want the money can I wait what oh my
god
where did it go ah dammit II went the
wrong way okay I gotta close them off
from going this way whoa no it can't go
that way
oh no can't cross the street oddly
enough right oh wait no no no it's
perfect I know no not that guy get out
of the way you douche no get out no no
there was a dead dog don't run over oh
you walked right over the dead dog
you're so gross okay there's a delicious
piece of bread that you can also double
as a dildo over here oh come on you're
not even interested in the dildo bread
you're such an ass like so many toys
eeeh but it can't actually do anything
with them let me move this over or maybe
he's just gonna go around it because
he's a total prick go around it yeah
that's right buddy
yeah that's right good move now if I
could just get that other guy to get out
of the way he's gonna move you better
move I got a guy Wow
oh come on sighs it's gonna be hard
[Music]
oh don't turn around and go right back
okay you're going that way that's good
that's good that's good it's good it's
good I like that
you've killed by these deadly
watermelons whatever the hell they are
oh they're just watermelons don't run
away you prick so what I'm gonna do is
I'm just gonna speed it up he's gonna
walk right by that's okay you can keep
on walking I got a few more other days
to do my dirty work to do what needs to
be done I don't know how that helps me
but but that's there I guess what how oh
that's so gross oh I missed you come on
no no no no money not yours no no no
money go away come yeah I saw your money
top it it's not your money it's not your
money no it's not your money
oh damn it fudge Nutter sickle bastard
ass you piece of crap cop I was gonna
kill him and you just gotten away okay
my plan is literally to ingenious
forwards I am too smart for my own good
this guy is going to find this money and
he's going to want to know cop got out
of there oh it's not your money it's not
yours
stop such an [ __ ] fine I'm gonna kill
him right behind you whoa right behind
you nice to see it off I think I won yes
dad I cannot click the game anymore
hello
hello hello hello hello okay
I'm gonna assume that I won okay so it
froze there but that actually was the
last level this was a very interesting
game I really like this now they
recently ran a sadly unsuccessful
Kickstarter and they haven't started up
another one but this is a great game
it's unique
I've never seen something like it before
it's simplistic but its stylized and I
really appreciate that so you can play
the demo down below all 10 levels maybe
you can find a kill them in a different
way that I have but either way this is a
great try I could see this being sold on
tablets like tomorrow you have a full
game here this is awesome go ahead and
do it I encourage you to you'd make a
lot of money so anyway thank you all so
much for watching leave a like if you
enjoyed this video and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]
Oh
[Music]